one of the things that kind of pervades
much right-wing ideology at least in the
united states
is seemingly
simple
obvious ideas
that everybody should clearly hear and
immediately say that makes sense and
adopt
which require no real deep thought of
any kind and
these include things like
uh hey
it's your money after all why should you
be taxed it's your money and you should
get to keep it well this is pretty
simple i don't know it makes sense of
course the real world is far more
complicated
um hey listen uh i mean we've got a
second amendment and so that's it you
just people can have whatever guns and
boo well hold on a second let's let's
actually think more deeply about some of
these issues
and when it comes to things like
unemployment
welfare benefits
social insurance
there's this attitude from the right
that's often based on the concept of
people just got to stop being lazy and
just like go and do stuff go and do
stuff
you need more money get a better job
uh just just just go go go do stuff
don't don't rely on other people don't
be lazy all these different things
and along these lines a very popular
meme that now is being repeated very
uncritically on fox news and in other
right-wing media
is as omicron spreads wildly
and some health agencies
in different states countries etc are
saying employers should be prepared
for
up to 25 of their workforce at any given
time to be out because of either a
coveted diagnosis or a covet exposure
that requires some degree of isolation
they are saying just just go to work
go to work and we have the epitome of
hypocrisy here from fox news is brian
kilmeade the fox and friends crew
appears to be hosting fox and friends
each alone in studios now we can't tell
whether these are all even fox studios
or summer home studios there are people
on other networks who have set up a room
in their home with a big tv screen
behind them and it looks like they're in
the studio but they're really at home we
don't know
but brian kilmeade while he is
co-hosting fox and friends alone in a
studio rather than on the couch with his
co-hosts for any of a variety of
different reasons is telling other
people
just go to work and live with kovid just
just get out there what are you doing
trying to be at home trying to be out
from work
pretty convenient when you can just get
it get your own studio or whatever it is
that he's doing all right let's take a
look at the video here and i want to
make it clear too
that i met so many teachers and ainsley
you your sister's teacher and your mom
was teacher uh and i met so many
teachers i went to about 18 cities over
the last uh two months and so many
people say i know fox doesn't like
teachers no no you got it all wrong
foxes in all teachers uh the unions that
are in control that they're forced to
join in order to get a job that's the
issue but guess what has changed you
know what he used to be he used to be us
on the couch he used to be almost every
republican uh political leader almost
everyone
saying go get the kids back in school
and the democrats get in charge and it's
like no no we're gonna we need money to
get schools ready and six feet apart and
then we get plexiglass in order to get
and now all of a sudden things have
changed if you see the new mayor of new
york city if you see laurie lutford of
chicago if you see what is happening in
los angeles everywhere you go in
massachusetts the moderate governor of
republican governor who has really gone
liberal on so many different causes is
now pushing back all on the same page
saying kids need to be in school and
guess the only people standing in the
way are teachers unions the kids need to
be in school the parents need to be
teaching in school the mayor's saying
get into school the governors are saying
getting to school the president's saying
get to school dr fauci said get to
school they're the only thing stopping
these kids are going to have now
remember all along
everybody
said it would be better for kids to be
in school
there was a point at which it would have
been outrageous to do it and schools
this i mean we're getting to the main
thing even this week some schools are
saying we're gonna do we're gonna go
remote for a week or two weeks and try
to get past this this omicron surge but
let's continue their learning curve
forever curtailed unless something
happens quickly and this should be our
mantra from here on in let's not get
caught up in the daily nuances of what
doctors in and what's out it's called
live with it go to work live with it go
to try get on a train get on a bus get
on a plane how do we live with it we can
no longer hide from it that's the 10 day
to five day rule now listen in the real
world uh there's parents that have to
deal with remote learning until they can
get control of their kids education now
there's some degree to which
kill meat is not wrong in that we are
literally going to have to learn to live
with it one way or the other how some
people live with it is going to be
different than how other people live
with it the the most optimistic scenario
is we've got another seven to ten days
maybe of this omicron surge and then a
decline meaning in seven to ten days
we'll be back where we are now and in
another seven to ten days we'll be to
where we were seven to ten days ago and
hopefully six weeks from now or so
things are looking here the way they
were they are looking in south africa
now that that would be the ideal
trajectory
but then the best case scenario is this
thing becomes endemic
and it will be roughly this severe
for a period of time
and hopefully over time the number of
cases gets down to you know what would
be sort of a steady predictable level
the way flu sort of is although there's
better flu seasons and worse flu seasons
we know that
and it continues to mutate because of
evolutionary pressure that generally
makes these things less severe over time
rather than more
in the less severe direction so there is
a degree to which we have to live with
it
we are in the middle of the biggest
spike
fox
and friends are each sitting by
themselves in a studio as he is saying
get on a bus go to school go here
teachers go in go even when you have a
lot of kids still unvaccinated
very easy and hypocritical for him to
say that and it's you know the it was
the aoc the thing they were saying about
aoc going to miami which we talked about
rules for thee and not for me
he's telling everybody else get on
public transit and just go to your job
where he is you know we can't tell he
may be working from home or isolated in
a studio
probably gets a chauffeured ride into
the studio or at least it's available i
don't know if he's taking it you know
we're we're sort of guessing here um
this is sort of a rules for the and not
for me sort of thing and just a complete
disconnect from the reality of what's
actually going on in the world and if
businesses have 25
25 of workers out
uh you don't think that cripples
businesses in a serious and significant
long-term way so it's not just hypocrisy
it's virtue signaling as well and we
should all be really skeptical about
accepting the stuff that these people
tell us